je suis stagiaire j'ai pas de garant
j'ai trois chiens deux chats et joue de
la batterie vas-y démerde-toi
[Applaudissements]
je te renouvelle ton stage et c'est
comme ça que tu me remercie Fuck You non
mais ok je vous explique il m'a
renouvelé mon stage la semaine dernière
c'était très gentil sauf qu'il m'a fait
un contrat franco-marocain c'est-à-dire
salaire en dirham et jour de repos
inch'Allah donc voilà donc c'est quand
même pas très très sympa voilà tu te
plains
et Besancenot ça peut partir en
cacahuète à n'importe quel moment voilà
bon Thierry petit débrie de la semaine
dernière sur Twitter beaucoup de
réactions sur votre interview de Pascal
Obispo comme Spartacus Network qui nous
dit Ardisson passe son temps à glorifier
les mecs de 50 ou 60 ans en couple avec
des nanas de 30 ans de moins pas
terrible et je suis bien d'accord je
trouve ça non mais je trouve ça
dégueulasse les mecs de 60 piges qui se
tapent des nanas de 30 ans moi ça me
scandalise
après ça dépend qui franchement non mais
c'est vrai non mais par contre un mec de
30 ans avec une fille de 60 ça n'a pas
d'intérêt ça s'appelle une brocante et
c'est dégueulasse
alors Olivier Besancenot bonsoir bonsoir
Olivier Besancenot c'est le c'est le
thon rouge de la politique en 2009 il
faisait 10% dans les sondages
aujourd'hui il est 1% si on fait rien il
va disparaître alors comme disait Gérard
sauter les tons mobiliser vous non mais
c'est vrai selon un sondage BVA cette
semaine les Français se disent
favorables à une primaire commune à
l'ensemble des parties de gauche et ils
aimeraient voir en priorité Manuel Valls
47% Macron 46% et en queue de Ploton
François Hollande 29 et Olivier
Besancenot 28%. vous pouvez pas être
derrière François Hollande plus personne
ne l'a même mon chat quand il le voit à
la télé il se met en boule non moi j'ai
envie que vous sortir de là franchement
Olivier j'en ai marre que vous traîniez
dans la rue Olivier il fait tellement de
manif dans sa vie que quand ils sont à
une odeur de merguez ça lui rappelle
plus le boulot que les vacances
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors j'ai très honnête avec vous j'ai
pas grandi avec vous parce que je suis
un peu mais non mais non mais c'est vrai
je suis un peu plus jeune moi les stars
du hip-hop quand j'étais jeune c'était
willy Denzey Billy Crawford
c'était hip-hop non mais en plus moi
c'est vrai que ça me parle pas trop
aux chansons qu'est-ce qu'on attend pour
[ __ ] le feu moi j'ai grandi en
Seine-et-Marne je veux dire si on
foutait le feu ça partait en feu de
forêt direct non mais honnêtement on
avait plus d'emmerdes avec les sangliers
qu'avec les flics
à 38 ans vous aviez dit que vous
n'alliez pas rappeler jusqu'à 50 ans
c'est loupé et aujourd'hui 50 ans vous
rappelez encore donc vous êtes la preuve
que quand on est jeune on dit beaucoup
de conneries
non mais c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
vous jouez dans le film éperdument qui
raconte l'histoire d'amour entre un
directeur de prison et une détenue je
sais le début ça fait début de film
porno enfin pas du tout dedans il y a
Guillaume Gallienne et un film porno
avec Guillaume Gallienne moi je regarde
pas
non mais ce qui est incroyable
d'ailleurs c'est que vous avez été
classé parmi les personnalités
européennes de moins de 30 ans les plus
influentes par le magazine Forbes voilà
alors qu'est-ce que ça veut dire être
influent je sais pas mais c'est bien
c'est bien d'ailleurs on va voir si vous
êtes vraiment influente ce que je
cherche un appart donc ça c'est mon
dossier
je suis stagiaire j'ai pas de garant
j'ai trois chiens deux chats et joue de
la batterie vas-y démerde-toi
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser
vous avez dit je ne reviens pas pour
l'argent j'ai le poker pour ça et Joey
Starr qui fait la Nouvelle Star vous
voulez pas lui apprendre le poker plutôt
Adèle Adèle Exarchopoulos vous avez dit
à propos de votre carrière j'avais envie
qu'on me laisse faire des erreurs voilà
pensez à quoi en disant ça à vos débuts
dans RS police scientifique
par exemple
Olivier Besançon vous êtes toujours
postier et vous êtes ancien chef de fil
de l'extrême gauche alors du coup vous
êtes ici sur votre temps de congé ou
votre temps de grève
[Applaudissements]
bonne émission merci beaucoup
la semaine prochaine et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de YouTube abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu